what's happening you bad [__]
it's Thursday
June the first the joint is here to talk
to you [__] today but before we
start how about a word from Fuji geese
let me tell you something
I've been using fujigi's since I started
Jujitsu they the first gear they gave me
was this heavy [__] thing forget it
they have Ultra lightweight geez that'll
change your [__] life and they're
cheap too but if you use my code Joey
Diaz Church
Joey you get 10 off all right so go to
fujigi they got great rash guards they
got great sweatshirts and hooded
sweatshirts and anything Jiu Jitsu based
for you the joint is also brought to you
by my favorite honor they were there and
we started
and they're still there today that tells
you the type of company they are from
the supplements to the kettlebells to
the club Bells the anything they have to
offer their workouts go to honor.com
right now check out the website check
out what they have to offer you if you
see something you like pressing [__]
Church Joey joint and get 10 off your
order and start your relationship with
Hana to make your life stronger I have
and it's panned out for me little by
little
let's get this [__] started it's
Thursday morning I miss you [__]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's Thursday June the first I'm very
sorry we haven't been on here for a few
weeks we had a couple holidays a couple
[__] disasters here in our personal
lives
Mike was in the hospital uh for a
weekend and then it was Memorial Day
weekend and then you know things just
kept getting deeper and deeper the wall
100 [__] percent on a Thursday
morning
uh everything's been great lately I've
been having a great time I have not seen
the burp movie or the Sebastian movie
yet
I see people already torturing them for
no [__] reason they should be very
bad about their accomplishment I feel
bad but hey welcome to the [__]
movie business the situation in hand
today is us talking about what's going
on what the future is basically a couple
weeks ago uh and it had nothing to do
with anybody it was just
it's getting rougher to do this
it's getting rough of me to do this uh
we tried it in the house for a while and
now
you know I don't know what happened over
the over the pandemic but I knew after
the pandemic I wasn't the same and I
listened some people could tell you
whatever the [__] they want I'll tell
you how it is
this wasn't the same I could just feel
myself pulling away from
stand up and everything else
you know when I moved here I want to
take some time to myself
Mike kept calling me and torturing me
that I'm a loser then I should do
something with my time
So I listened to him I took his lead and
I could feel from the first three
podcasts that I had lost something that
it was completely different
and I wanted to do something completely
different I just wanted to be like Paul
Harvey for you guys who don't know who
Paul Harvey is he's a [__] old guy
that I grew up on
that would have a radio show every day
at noon time that spoke about nothing
but it was the most interesting [__]
show I ever listened to in my life you
know
and uh I love what Bill Byrd did I love
what Theo does by himself you know I I
wanted to give it a try I thought it
would be great
just to come up here and free ball and
[__] and whatever but
it didn't pan out for me guys you know
and then uh guest I can have Jesus on
here you guys don't want him you know
what I'm saying like it it's like you
know and I understand and I understand
and then everything changed listen man
I've been doing this podcast [__] now
since 2011.
over a decade when nobody even knew what
a [__] podcast was
like if you get in to do a podcast today
you have people that you look up to well
you know Rogan's doing this uh you know
[__] shell sun is doing this
the bodega boys are doing this when we
got into it it wasn't like we didn't
know nothing
I didn't know if I had to interview
people what do you think I [__] came
up interviewing people I'm a criminal
people interviewed me you know what I'm
saying like I never interviewed [__]
nobody
so you know this is all new to us when
we started this in 2011 and again
I'm very grateful for the podcast
movement because without the podcast I
would not be here my career would have
been something completely [__]
different
because I always wanted to have a
podcast I didn't even know what a
podcast was I just wanted the
opportunity to tell my story and uh
that was the great thing about it and it
was so new and interesting and everybody
jumped on it and we were having a great
[__] time
but I had to pull the church
when we were doing [__] tremendous I
mean pulling the church just let you
know
where you're at I I the church was great
and I was having a great time and even
during the pandemic we were getting
great numbers everything was working out
and once you know we were going to
change it around
but Boom the pandemic happened and I
didn't shut it down because I was brain
dead then I shut it down because it was
time to [__] get the [__] out of
there and I had to get Lee out of there
I had to get my friends out there and
look at all the people that left how
many people left and really left melee
and Steve Simone everybody else is
treading back there well I wanted to go
take a look now I'm doing sets now man
you gotta stick to your [__] words
sometimes and that's something that
that's a that's a different between
being a player and being a [__] King
you got to see certain things and you
gotta attack them before somebody else
lets you know like I always said I've
taken great pride and not have somebody
telling me when I got to leave the room
I've always taken great pride in that
and that's why a couple weeks ago I was
like you know what man this thing is not
working I we shut it down the audio just
to see if we make it a little easier
and it still felt like a struggle to me
you know at times
and uh I just want to be honest with
everybody that I think my podcast Day
Has Come and gone but at least I saw it
and at least I don't have to [__]
have people tell you you know this is
over I mean I I feel it guys you know
you have to live a little to have a
[__] podcast I haven't lived the last
three years
it's like I've been on planes or gone to
Houston or you know the the most
interesting thing for me about having a
podcast and living your [__] life and
then reporting on it and in a certain
way that you could do it whether it's a
concert whether it's a movie whatever
the [__] you know a golf game I don't
give a [__]
but uh
you know it just wasn't working anymore
and
for weeks
I just sat here and would say to myself
why do I keep doing this
why do I keep doing it is it the money
is it what what is it
and then I realized man I'm out of
stories you know what
I just did something that
on paper looks so great but in reality
it was so hard I just emptied my heart
of everything I had in it like whether
it was good or bad or things that made
me embarrassed into a [__] book and
then I sat across Mike and Lee and
Felicia and told stories on how you know
these things affected my life and stuff
well it was great for while it lasted
but now after the book is out I'm all
out of [__] ideas guys I have nothing
to compare it to in fact if I don't ever
have to tell a story about my [__]
past again
it would make me so [__] happy like
it would make me so [__] happy guys
so in other words yeah I'm kind of over
it a little bit
I feel bad because I know I gotta you
guys are loyal soldiers and your family
at this point listen to people that were
soldiers disappeared the people that
stuck around the new people we got
you guys are family you know from the
little linguses to the [__] uh
quadrax there's tons of names Sergio
Ortega's I mean Sergio Ortega may have
been together since the [__] Beauty
and the Beast
and we have relationship you know my
buddy up in Pittsburgh it's been a great
[__] run man
but I just don't have the time no more
to put into it like I did before and it
makes me realize how much time I was
taken away from my family
you know when I got into stand up I was
a lone [__] Soldier
and if you knew anything about me
I wanted to stay alone Soldier for the
rest of my life especially after what I
went through
who wants to lose another daughter who
wants to you know get betrayed by
somebody or things don't work out and
now you ruin somebody else's life
I never wanted to do these things but
they evolved and they happened I was
speaking to my buddy Carlos this morning
and uh him and I have similar lives you
know
he was a [__] up I was a [__] up you
know we grew up together I grew up with
his family and his family's house eating
dinner there and hanging out with him
and I don't know we reconnected maybe 20
years ago to a guy that's got a house
and a beautiful backyard with a pool and
he's got dogs and weights back there and
he's got two kids and a beautiful wife
and when him and I are together I always
go to him hey
we didn't see this
did you see this and he's like not in a
million [__] years that we see you
know when Mike told me he was having
kids and stuff I could see Mike having
kids and getting married he's a nice guy
he never hit nobody in the head with a
stick and never mugged nobody never
broke into somebody's house
but where I was coming from
this was I mean I still walk around I
can't believe it
I still walk around and I can't believe
that a house
comedy paid for a house like I I cannot
believe that
there was a time comedy couldn't pay for
my lunch
there was a time that for years I
struggled making rent and I was a
regular at the store and doing this and
doing that
and you [__] struggled and you know
what somewhere along the line my luck
changed
and I got to get out of debt and you
know just put away money because I knew
I wasn't gonna stay in California I
never bought anything in California the
only thing I had was a [__] license
that told you I lived in California but
I wasn't a member of any of that [__] I
always knew that there was no way I was
buying a house here I didn't wanna
die out there there was no [__] way
and I'm really proud of these things
right now today
and I'm gonna appoint my life guys I
gotta be honest with you I don't care
you like when somebody calls you they're
like hey man
did you listen to this thing I really
don't care
so sad guys
you know it's like I stopped even
listening to YouTube you know my agent
sent me some speakers and I started
listening to my [__] music again and
if not I'll come in here and put an
almond or something but I couldn't go on
YouTube anymore
just that opening page of and I'm like
where are these people coming from with
all these videos about Brendan and this
guy and everybody's a bad guy today and
listen I don't care about that [__] but
it's like
it just got old it just got old man you
know I have friends now that call me and
talk to me about stand up and
I gotta be honest here
I don't know what the [__] they're
talking about
you know the only person I talk to about
stand up and enjoy it anymore is leaked
I have a great time talking to Lee
because I really relate to what he's
doing I like what he's doing I like the
beginnings of Comedy
this [__] that happens at the end I
didn't like it at all guys I [__]
didn't like it at all
it was a little overwhelming and uh
you know guys it's nice to give videos a
break
it gets old we in our minds as comedians
we don't know we start believing what
you guys say to us and
we start believing that you guys need
more videos and you guys need more of
this and after a while we don't see what
we're doing that we're just becoming
Vince Vaughn
you know a lot of yous don't know who
Vince Vaughan is I like Vince Vaughn he
was a good actor but 20 years ago if you
had a movie about black people you put
Vince Vaughn in if you had a movie about
Chinese people you put Vince Vaughn in
and he's just over saturated himself it
was just a little too much and now where
do you see events form
nowhere you know he's a great actor he
did some great [__] things but
somewhere along the line he was in
[__] everything
and I don't know guys when I got into
the movie business listen my patterns or
people like Eddie Murphy and [__] Eddie
Murphy when he started
had the perfect career he did a movie
with somebody else he stole the movie
then they gave him 48 hours and he stole
that [__] movie and then they came
back they finally put a ton of money
into him and they gave him Beverly Hills
Cop and he worked it from there and he
worked it from there
but you know what you don't see Eddie
and everything
it said a couple years ago you saw
Tiffany haddish and everything
TV shows kids stories whatever I was
happy for her that she was making a ton
of [__] loot but at the same time I'm
like the more you expose yourself
it's less later it's less later like
calm it down a little bit we've lost
that we don't give a [__] we'll do 22
movies in a year
and expect you to see them all [__] you
guy yeah and I didn't expect me to do a
podcast in one week and Peter listen to
them all
you know it's like a never-ending
desperation you know
it's really funny today
later on this afternoon I have a zoom
with uh I'm starting to talk to people
about selling them the book rights you
know
and it's so weird that
if this would have happened 20 years ago
I couldn't come I couldn't con I
couldn't compose myself
I'd be [__] my pants and pissing
blood and jumping up and down and
snorting coke and doing
so many other things I know that this
these meetings I got and I got about 15
of them
I know that these meetings I could go
into them with a non-desperado attitude
causes a lot of [__] problems
not for me but for them because I'm not
desperate I could give a [__] if you buy
this book or not
I could give a Frenchman's [__] I wrote
this just for me to clean my conscience
and to get it out there
if you bought this you'd make me happy
because you put some income in me and my
daughter go to college but besides that
I mean you know
it's not like I'm going in there when I
was 40 when I thought it was going to be
a little
a death or a life situation and that's
how you take those meetings again if I
get this oh my God I can finally breathe
you know and you never breathe it was
like when I got the longest yard I was
finally going to do this when I got
Spider-Man 2 I was gonna do this when I
got this I was going to do this when I
shot and nothing happened
nothing happened
so now I'm going into these meetings and
I'm not desperate at all it's like my
friend said to him are you excited about
pitching I go to be honest with you I
ain't pitching
they're picture me yeah
that kind of pitched me
so
am I excited I'm proud I'm very happy
I'm very happy for Erica
but at the same time I'm not going in
there like I did when I was 43. I'm
gonna go in there and go hit me
what do you guys want to do all right
I'll get back to you now it's a
different situation if I would have
known these things I would have [__]
done these things earlier in my career
but everything came when it comes and
now you have to deal with it you know
whatever am I looking forward to these
meetings if you know anything about me
guy
not really
just give me the loot I'm like Biggie
Smalls give me the look give me the loot
if you guys know anything about me I
don't I could care less if they shoot a
movie
I could care less if they shoot a TV
show
the only thing I want is for them to
hold me for like five years I got like
20 friends that are authors that every
book they put out gets optioned
and they get option for years and they
don't hear anything about it because you
have to wait for that topic to get hot
and then you publish that book or
publish that movie you've always got it
in your Vault of things
so I'd rather are you [__] kidding me
I don't you know
yeah do you know how many [__] do you
know how many moons have to be aligned
for your TV show or your movie to go do
you have any [__] ideas listen guys I
know
off the top of my hand I know four
comedians
that shot pilots and their shows got
picked up and they shot 10 13 series 10
episodes and guess what
they're still waiting for the episodes
to go up
all that materials just oh that material
guys so there is no expectations out of
me I know exactly what I'm getting
myself into I'm listening to them and
it's very interesting
my wife sent me a review the other day
she was at work and some one of her
co-workers said I I went looking for
tremendous and I found this reveal
you gotta watch this interesting and my
wife Watson she sent to me she goes
watch this [__] video
and there was a guy talking about
tremendous and how he was a fan and how
he enjoyed the book no he enjoyed the
podcast but he enjoyed the book a lot
more
and he said that he was really happy for
me now this guy's not an industry guy
this guy was just a guy giving a review
he said he was interested he was excited
for me because he knew that
I could do whatever the [__] I wanted to
know
he goes if he doesn't want to do a
podcast he doesn't have to do a podcast
if he wants to write magazine articles
he could write magazine articles
whatever the [__] he wants to do now
this opened up another door
so in my decision came
to stop doing the podcast it was just to
take a breather
just to see where my head is at
just to see what topic we're going to
come back with because this topic ain't
[__] working on me comparing my [__]
that it's not working guys uh I stopped
watching the news during the pandemic so
I I really am not on top of
what's going on in the world and guys
when I talked to Mike and I talked to
Lee I'll ask him what's going on out
there and they'll tell me I don't know
what's going on out there and guys like
I said I really don't care at this point
in my life I care about getting healthy
I care about my family I care about my
friends you know I care about Mike and
Lee and these guys that were you know
they're in the struggle like I was it's
excited to see them D'Agostino and Eric
Rocha and these guys are young guys
that's where my interest goes now honest
to God guys I could care less about
stars or celebrities or any of that [__]
and that you guys know I'm the worst
celebrity in the world for starters I'm
not a celebrity but if you people want
to call me a celebrity just note that
I'm the worst celebrity in the world I
don't have a BMW I don't have a business
agent I don't have a [__] assistant I
don't have any of that [__] it's me my
balls and my heart that's all I [__]
ever had I don't need any of that [__]
so what I'm trying to do here is just
close the door
to see what door opens
that's it nobody's saying I'm shutting
down anything I just want to close one
door to see what opens
I want to see what's out there I want to
see what I've been missing
I'm 60. I want a whole new [__] set
of rules man
I want something different in my life I
don't know if it's a podcast I don't
know if it's a movie career it's none of
the above I just want to be happy I want
to be a good dad now
and that's where I'm at I I [__] love
going to Jujitsu I get beat up yesterday
I got thrown around the room two weeks
ago somebody banged my head off the
[__] mat
I [__] had a headache for two days I
feel like [__] one of these guys with
trt whatever that brain damage just [__]
I've been sweating that but you know
what guys I have a good time going there
it's my social life now
I play bocce ball I enjoy that it's one
night a week it's [__] 30 minutes
with a bunch of old Italians we're owing
three we scored our yeah we scored our
first two points last night with
terrible
I'm just trying to have a good time guys
I didn't do any of this [__] growing up
I didn't do any of this [__] for the
last 30 years I haven't done any of this
because I always thought comedy was more
important and I was right it was
important at the time at that time when
I was 31 it was important for me to tell
you [__] to shove your wedding
invitation up your asses and it was
important to tell you guys that I wasn't
going to some [__] party on a
Saturday night that had to do a comedy
show instead and and those things were
important to me at the time now
I was at a barbecue Sunday when I got
back from the shop
Sunday night
and I was there with my neighbor who I
[__] adore this dude
his name is Steve he works in the city
and he works nights
and we were having a good time at this
barbecue you know it was like six
o'clock the kids were in the pool and
just some dads were just talking [__]
you know I had a couple [__] bong
hits in me
and pieces of sillies [__] tiramisu
uh
whatever and I was just having a good
time with him and he said to me I gotta
get ready to go and I go where the [__]
you going it's Labor day goes I gotta go
to work tonight
he goes I didn't work last night
and at one point he just looked over him
and he goes I gotta tell you something I
really enjoyed this job 10 years ago
because I [__] hate it now
he goes I hate having to do this and I
go watch this and he goes leave when I'm
having a good time he goes I'm sick of
doing it I go I think of doing that for
30 years
and I ain't gonna lie to you guys
sometimes it's a blessing to get out of
a party you know what I'm saying like
sometimes it's good to say oh my God I
have a set at 7 30.
but
sometimes you're just having such a good
time you're like really
I gotta [__] get in the car now and
go do [__] comedy or something I
remember a couple [__] like last year
when I thought I had the comedy bug I
thought it was going to be John Mulaney
and uh I was doing some warm-up sets at
Uncle Vinnie he's one of my favorite
joints
and I just told somebody
like I go listen
the thing I hate the most about comedy
is when I have to do comedy that's when
[__] happens and then I gotta leave at
seven o'clock and it was a beautiful
night it was like a June night or
something Austin we were outside me and
my daughter playing Hoops or something
we heard like a ice cream man right
and it was [__] Mr Softee like I'm
like Mr swap these in this neighborhood
I was so [__] excited and the
neighbors came out it was like 6 30 at
night all the neighbors came out and
we're out there talking and all of a
sudden my friend came to get me he goes
you gotta we gotta go to Uncle Vinnie's
and I remember saying right then and
there I'm gonna get in that car but this
is the last time this is happening
I'm not doing this again
this is what usually happens when you
book a date I'm gonna tell you what
happened to me
this last this is why guys always
remember one thing
the universe will give you signs
the universe will give you signs it it
always does if you catch it good for you
if you don't catch it the first time
you'll catch after about three mishaps
after you [__] fall off the scooter
and Bang Your Head on the [__]
concrete you'll go Society uh the
universe didn't give me a hint
how to get out of this [__] mess here
you know
I booked the the
I booked the the [__] book signing
last Wednesday I did New Jersey 12 that
morning
the Vogel theater came out [__] great
place you know what's the name of that
in the Asbury Park or in Red Bank I
forget what it's called anyway it
doesn't [__] matter
they reached out and said would you be
interested in doing a book signing here
and I said yes let me just tell you a
story guys and they said yes okay within
an hour I had a call from the agents all
right the ticket's gonna be a hundred
bucks and I go why a hundred bucks and
he goes because it's a comedy thing
you're gonna have to go up there and
hire somebody to help you interview you
just a bunch of [__] and I'm like but
the book is 25.
he goes yeah but right away I was
already ticked off so finally I got him
down to 50 Buck tickets
I go I could live on 25 and 25 for the
[__] book we'll do a book signing but
then they started adding things to this
and I was like you know what this
doesn't sound fun
right like this and next thing you know
my wife comes to me and she goes did you
book June 8th yet and I go no they're
trying to book me on June 8th and
another date I think the 28 something
she goes let me look she goes well you
can't do the eighth because you have a
[__]
uh your daughter has a recital and you
can't do the 20 something because it's
something else that night I'm like [__]
there you go
that's the first sign I shouldn't be
[__] doing book signings and [__]
then I'm in labor damn down the shore
Friday
anybody expect your phone to ring last
it's [__] Labor Day okay so I gotta
put the girls uh the families came down
we all went to the pool we took a walk
around LBI
and then we went back it was on 4 30 I'm
like I'm [__] tired I gotta take a
[__] nap I didn't sleep well the
night before
I [__] uh take a little hour nap
Friday when I wake up I got a message
that says I got a movie
and I'm like what
how can I have a movie there's a writer
strike I'm like they made it offer I
thought it was like a dream
it said my agent's name and offer and
I'm like what the [__] who made an offer
on me there's nothing going on
and it's for this uh Kevin James movie
Christine Ritchie you know it's a cons
Film Festival it shoots four weeks I
would have six days on it but when does
it start shooting the [__] hate so
it's like you know guys that's the
Universe telling me to mind my [__]
business and that's
the 10 times it's happened this year
where I've thought about making plans or
something awesome it's just it's just
not meant to happen and you could sit
there and be upset and whatever but when
something's not meant to go it's just
not meant to go it's not in the [__]
guards
so that's why I'm walking away from that
[__] I I
you know I don't know if I'm gonna do
the New York thing
this fall I haven't decided yet let me
give the podcast the Breather let me
give everything a breather
let me clear my head for like 60 [__]
days and
the worst thing that could happen is I
can come back stronger
that's the worst that could happen guys
so listen you bad [__] I'm not
going nowhere and this ain't goodbye I'm
just taking a [__] breathing
and I'm going to take some time to
myself and see
what it that I really want to [__] do
or what type of podcast I might come
back with a tennis podcast
I might come back with a podcast about
Christianity I might come back I don't
know I don't know guys
but I can't keep doing what I was doing
here do you guys it's not fair to you
guys it's not fair to me it's not fair
to Mike it's it's not fair to anybody
you know it just wasn't working and it's
nobody's fault I took a chance
you know I took 2 000 chances
I did good on maybe you know a thousand
fifty of them the rest fall apart that's
the percentage guys nothing to be
ashamed of nothing to be upset about
I'm gonna go home have a roast beef
sandwich and come back a lot stronger
think about what I could do
to be a better person a better podcaster
or if not I don't know
I don't know there's got to be something
else I could do
if you have any ideas let me know if you
need to get a hold of me I'm on patreon
I think you're trying to go down to five
dollars
just come on board talk with us whatever
if you need some advice I put some uh 15
minute audio podcast on there nothing
too serious we try to put a movie of the
week and we're gonna try to figure out
to do some type of book review on the
patreon because I'm sure a lot of the
patreon people want to ask some
questions
and without further Ado [__] I
love you
have a great [__] June
and I will be in touch with you like I
said if you need to get a hold of me you
know what a [__] find me Instagram
Facebook I don't know you know twitch I
don't [__] know
I love you [__] stay black have
a great summer and I'll talk to you
[__] soon and now for a word my
[__] sponsors
all right you bad [__] thank
you for being here
thank you for all your support over the
years I love you [__] but most
importantly thank you for understanding
you know like I said sometimes you got
to close one door
to open up another one that's what we're
trying to do here but before we leave
please go to onnit.com the summer's
coming you might need a little boost a
new mood some [__] uh Alpha Brain the
new Alpha Brain which is [__]
tremendous I'm about to start another
cycle here in like two weeks go to
audit.com look at the club back to the
[__] kettlebells listen I've been
with them for 10 years I love them to
death anyway go to on it if you see
something you like
pressing code Joey or church and get 10
off your order also for health benefits
I love
fuji geez fujigi's have been a part of
my BJJ career since the [__]
beginning I love them they're Ultra
lightweight they got medium weights they
got rash guards they're tough they last
and they're just a nice lightweight gee
looking through them I'm Gonna Get You
ten percent off at Fuji when you use
code Joey or church
again thank you very much for being a
part of this and I'll be in touch with
you [__] if you need me I'll see
you on patreon stay black
[Music]
thank you